a bold new Prime Time lineup for Fox
News it's kicking off tonight it all
starts at 7 p.m with Laura Ingram Jessie
and his prime time crew are then heading
over to 8 P.M John Hannity at 9pm and
Greg Gutfeld exclamation point Parks
himself at 10. and Trace Gallagher caps
things off with Fox News at night at 11.
Laura and Sean thank you for joining us
here on the five we're excited to kick
it off Laura let's start with you since
7 P.M that's when it all begins
this is Ingram and this is my world
I'm kind of losing my voice is that a
bad Omen for the show I don't know what
that means no actually I've heard that
there's this old ancient wise tale that
if you lose your voice right before you
take over prime time it's actually
really good luck
guys I have my um Cardinal mug that's
gonna with tea in it it's only tea gut
fell there's no bourbon
um Cardinal mug and that's gonna solve
my voice problem so it'll be fun to tune
in who knows what'll happen tonight in
no tease you're gonna can you tell give
us one little hint well we are going to
um hit the the Justin Trudeau is
attacking the likes of all of us I'm
going to explain it what he said and why
we really don't need to be lectured by
our neighbors to the north as much as we
love them and we do love them don't we
we all love them so much certainly so
we'll talk about that in the state of
the race so we're gonna hit all that and
Sean Hannity at 9 00 PM where we have
found your your Legions of fans always
like first of all I mean for a few
minutes I guess we could call the show
the hit show The Seven because there's
seven of us
um which I would imagine you guys have a
hard enough time managing the time
between you all and congrats on on all
of everybody's success here uh we have
Cornell Weston interesting question
about him uh whether or not he's not
just running for the Democratic
nomination but whether he'd run a third
party we got the great one Mark Levin we
have an investigative report on you know
why won't the bidens acknowledge the
fact that they have seven grandchildren
and I'm just going to try and keep up
with Laura and Jesse and Greg is
impossible to keep up with so I just
gave up
bathroom all right anybody else want to
bring things I mean we've got one
no questions like CNN after Trump's
indictment yes never seen so many faces
but actually people are smiling so it's
not quite this by the way yeah guys
heads are blowing off shoulders on MSNBC
right now because they have us you know
on like multiple screens in their
offices heads are literally just blowing
off bodies all across left wing left
wing up uh animals in America so this
this picture this block especially with
Janine there and Gutfeld and Hannity
they can't take it Dana's the nice
person in this group okay let me just
say that nice one and Harold
we've only known each other 30 years
tonight what do we got
so tonight we have the 17 million dollar
anti-racist hiking trail that Joe
Biden's building that we're going to
explore uh we have a shark attack we
have the Indian chief who's upset about
the Ben Jerry's owners taking their land
and we have RFK Jr saying some explosive
things about bio weapons it's it's one
of the best shows I've ever done I have
no idea what's going to happen on
Tuesday
this Show's good
one day at a time we're gonna start off
with a little nude twister uh no we're
gonna do I'm doing I'm gonna be doing a
lot of cocaine in the a block
story and then I'm gonna do a B Block on
the great Jennifer Rubin uh a legendary
poster uh calling this and we're going
to be doing uh Greg's animal friends
which is the new segment and then wow
great video from my weekend in Florida
where I did something really bad
you got to watch it they're sound
effects it's pretty pretty uh disgusting
sound effects
I am with a dog by the way guys guys I
ran into Brett Bear at the airport this
morning and I felt like a really well a
bad mom because I was trying to get my
son off to go to Minneapolis he's going
there to work for a couple weeks and I'm
I didn't my boarding pass didn't print
and I was going to a different place so
he had to go and I was I couldn't get
him through right because I didn't have
his path anyway it's a long story who
walks up bruh Brett Bear
he says um is there a problem here I
said yeah could you bring my son through
clear and get him on the plane and he
did it he did it and he saved the day oh
that's a great story
about that tonight yeah and he told me
he had the pope booked and the D Block
tonight of Special Report so that's all
so Harold you and I are on bread show
tonight right yeah we'll be with the
Pope yes
Harold and Dana how could you do better
Laura and Sean thank you so much Jesse
and Grace good luck don't miss our brand
new Prime Time lineup starting tonight 7
P.M Eastern and one more thing is up
next hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now